-Performing "Killing Me"
from his upcoming debut album,
"Ivory," give it up for
Omar Apollo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Why do I depend on you? ♪
♪ 16, about to pull up ♪
♪ Think 'bout your body
too much ♪
♪ I'm feelin' you for real ♪
♪ Missin' the party for what? ♪
♪ There ain't nobody but us ♪
♪ Love me like I'm gonna die ♪
♪ Touch me like you fantasize ♪
♪ Hold me like you know you
provide to ♪
♪ They wanna lie, too ♪
♪ Just wanted to slide through ♪
♪ What I do makes me wonder
if I'm alright ♪
♪ Holding back feelings like
it's the end of my life ♪
♪ That's right,
you're killin' me ♪
♪ Qué locura solo piense a ti ♪
♪ Cuando me tocas y me
llamas, oh, Lord ♪
♪ Adrenaline,
tryna meet right back ♪
♪ Skeletons that
I don't hold back ♪
♪ Try to stop,
do you feel relaxed? ♪
♪ Love you, but you make feel ♪
♪ Love me like I'm gonna die ♪
♪ Touch me like you fantasize ♪
♪ Hold me like you know you
provide to ♪
♪ They wanna lie, too ♪
♪ Just wanted to slide through ♪
♪ What I do makes me wonder
if I'm alright ♪
♪ Holding back feelings like
it's the end of my life ♪
♪ That's right,
you're killin' me ♪
♪ That's right, that's right,
that's right ♪
♪ That's right,
that's right, that's right ♪
♪ That's right, that's right,
that's right ♪
♪ That's right,
that's right, that's right ♪
♪ That's right, that's right,
that's right ♪
♪ That's right,
that's right, that's right ♪
♪ That's right, that's right,
that's right ♪
♪ That's right,
that's right, that's right ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]